hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
this is the samsung galaxy s20
ultra and it is samsung's attack of the
numbers
[Music]
so this is it this huge phone here is
samsung's highest and
most expensive flagship phone ever
and there's a lot of words samsung could
have chosen to use here they could have
gone
plus or max they could have gone
pro but they went ultra
ultra ultra extremist
radical yeah i think that's that's
actually pretty accurate so if the
question is how can you possibly justify
a new phone
that expensive samsung's answer is by
throwing all the hardware at you
all the specs every single big number
they can possibly think of
they're going into this phone it looks
on paper like a great idea how could a
phone
with snapdragon 865 16 gigs of ram
512 gigs of ufs 3.0
108 megapixels 100x zoom
8k 5000 milliamp hours
120 hertz 1440p
5g how could this phone be anything
other than
the best well i'll tell you but let's
start with the design though just
because i think
it's actually the least ultra thing
about this phone and it's pretty simple
actually
it's a massive phone glass sandwich with
a gigantic
recognizable double camera bump uh
expandable storage at the top
speaker at the bottom rip headphone jack
you know on one hand it kind of blends
in with the smartphones of today
especially in samsung's lineup
but on the other hand there's no
mistaking it actually remember when
smartphone displays were getting bigger
and bigger and then they first crossed
over
five inches like average and then they
sort of evened out at 5.3 inch
and people thought it was kind of
getting crazy and then samsung because
who else
uh came out with the galaxy mega
that's really a phone they came out with
and named that had a 6.3 inch display it
was just hilarious like no one else
would try that but this phone was the
size of a tablet
with the form factor of a phone it
really was the mega
phone yet here we are now today with
galaxy s20 ultra
bigger than any galaxy mega or any
galaxy note even has ever been with a
6.9 inch display it's huge for me it
still
fits in my pocket and it's usable for me
but it might not be for everyone
clearly giant phones aren't for everyone
i gotta say though for an ultra phone
the color options of glossy black glossy
gray
are a bit underwhelming of course
channel sponsor dbrand will gladly step
up and customize the look on the back
and you can get as wild as this robot
camo skin but
don't let that be a cop-out samsung i'm
hoping for a little more variety
next time till then i'll link that skin
below one thing you do get from a huge
phone though is a huge display so just
to give you the numbers
6.9 inch diagonal 120 hertz
1440p and stop me if you've heard this
before but samsung has once again
made the best display in any smartphone
best brightness
colors contrast best viewing angles of
any smartphone display
i've ever seen i feel like i'm starting
to sound like displaymate it's the
highest a plus i've ever given
just you'll know when you see it and
it's not just the high end spec and big
numbers
they've also flattened out the edges of
the display so it doesn't spill over the
sides anymore
and i appreciate that from a usability
perspective
and i hope they keep that trend up
throughout the rest of their lineup love
that
and if i have any gripes really it's
that the ultrasonic fingerprint reader
underneath the screen
is basically the same as last year
there's no real substantial improvements
and that's fine it's still a decently
fast and responsive one
and once you learn where it is with
muscle memory it's kind of quick but i
was hoping these would get
bigger and faster from generation to
generation and that hasn't happened yet
now it is worth noting you don't get all
the big numbers
straight out the box this phone is
actually 1080p
60hz out the box pretty basic
and you can either notch it up to 120
hertz
or 1440p but not both at the same time
personally i'm picking 120 hertz every
single time i was waiting for or asking
for
the high refresh rate from samsung and
we finally got it and it's great
the difference between 60hz and 120hz
in like 90 of what you're doing on your
phone which is scrolling
it's fantastic and then the display also
has a 240hz touchsense refresh so
no matter what resolution you're in it
keeps it feeling snappy
and responsive as expected which is just
what we've seen
in these gaming phones that came before
it now do i wish they would let us use
this phone at 120 hertz
and 1440p full resolution at the same
time
yeah i wish they would allow it right
now that's disabled i originally thought
it might be a snapdragon 865 limitation
but it turns out it's not they just
don't enable it because they probably
think it would crush battery but i say
if you're paying
1400 bucks for this phone and you know
what you're getting yourself into
you can still put it at 60 hertz 1080p
out the box but let us enable it if we
really want to maybe they can enable
that with a software update
and you know just put a little
disclaimer hey you turn these both on
it'll crush your battery but you paid
for the phone so you get to turn it on
all right so let's talk about that
battery
five thousand milliamp hours on the s20
ultra and this is one of those specs
that usually translates
pretty well from paper to real life the
bigger the battery the better
and this one's getting two big thumbs up
from me we know 5 000 milliamp hours is
huge but i was just a tiny bit worried
about how well it would do
powering a giant bright 6.9 inch 120hz
display
turns out it's perfectly fine i've been
getting consistently
six plus hours of screen on time at the
end of every day easy
with battery to spare heavy stuff gaming
a lot of navigation while driving
and i've never killed it in a single day
so i don't even worry about it anymore
to be honest i was thinking
that i was going to have to take a few
extra days of testing to flip it down to
60 hertz and see how much battery that
saves me
but yeah i don't have to this is an
all-day phone at 120 hertz which is dope
but all right let's just face it
the big numbers that you guys are
probably most curious about and how well
they translate
is around the back of this phone and
that's the cameras so that's that 108
megapixels
that's 8k video and that's even printed
on the back of this phone
the 100x space zoom but as we've
hopefully learned by now
numbers on the spec sheet for cameras
don't always translate super well to
real world performance i've seen about a
million
64 megapixel cameras that are worse than
the 12 megapixel cameras
in the pixel and the iphone so for me
seeing how hard samsung was leaning into
this camera upgrade for the s20 ultra
my real question at the beginning of
this was hey can samsung
actually make the best camera in any
smartphone
uh i have a lot of thoughts about this
camera so right off the bat i'm gonna
say this is better in some ways than
their previous cameras
but worse in other ways actually so it
still falls solidly
in third place for me i i still prefer
photos from the pixel and the iphone
more often
than images coming from samsung but that
doesn't mean the numbers mean nothing
by default this main camera is doing
binning that kicks out
a 12 megapixel photo and it is the
sharpest
most detailed 12 megapixel photo out
there which i love
that's one of the things that's my
favorite about it and these are
classic samsung bright and colorful
usually bringing up shadows and
smoothing out faces the whole thing
that hasn't changed there's also the
ultrawide camera which is the softest of
the three cameras but
i'm still glad it's there it's giving us
that first person
the fun perspective and it even has
samsung's much improved night mode
in ultra wide which some others just
straight up don't do and then there is
of course
the full 108 megapixel mode that can be
toggled on
and yes that did produce a bit more
detail
which is useful especially if you're
planning on zooming in and cropping
after you take that big photo but for
the difference in file size and the
inconvenience of
always having to turn it on i ended up
not really feeling like i needed it most
of the time
i was happy with the 12 megapixel shots
but if you pay a little bit more
attention to that main camera
especially with close-up subjects
there's a little bit more to notice
there so keep this in mind
the main 108 megapixel camera is
massive like it's physically much larger
than most other smartphone camera
sensors and for the most part it's a
general rule
the larger the sensor the better you're
letting in more light you get bigger
pixels
it's just a typical good thing to have a
larger sensor and that's fine
um but for those of us familiar with
large sensor photography
and video larger sensors have a look
like that's when you start to get this
naturally blurry foreground and
background
and this shallow depth of field in this
case the sensor on this phone is
so big and that dual aperture feature
that they've shipped in a couple
previous samsung flagships
is now gone so it is wide open at f 1.8
all the time these things combine to
make a
razor thin plane of focus and so things
that aren't in that plane of focus
by even a couple of inches are out so
when i took photos of closer up subjects
which i do i guess more than normal but
enough to notice this uh you would not
only see that the background was
naturally blurred without portrait mode
but really only part of the subject is
actually in focus
and you can see the rest is falling out
of focus but in this smeared
fringe bad looking bokeh
normally this isn't such a weird thing
because with a big
high quality sensor and glass that's
just the background
falling naturally out of focus but on
these tiny smartphone optics
the bokeh just isn't quite as beautiful
and you really do start to notice the
fringing
and unnatural looking blurred background
now and i also think
that this may have contributed to the
autofocus issues you may have heard
about
on the s20 ultra autofocus on this phone
for me has been
unusually jumpy and kind of
unpredictable and actually
missed focus a few times especially with
close focus
and close subjects and i just haven't
had a flagship phone have issues like
that
in a long time and i was trying to
figure out why i think the
razer thin plane of focus from not
having dual aperture mode
and probably some not perfectly
optimized software has made
autofocus on the s20 ultra feel kind of
buggy now samsung has already promised
some software updates that should fix
these issues
and i believe they can probably mitigate
a lot of these autofocus
issues with software but at the end of
the day you can't
beat the physics of having a larger
sensor
and not so great optics so i think that
fringing
and that very sharp falloff of the razor
thin depth of field
will continue okay galaxy s20 ultra will
also shoot
8k video that's the new feature these
snapdragon 865 phones are getting
and that should be right up my alley so
of course i go to test it
and i am very impressed with the images
you can get off the smartphone sensor
the stills you can take from the video
at 33 megapixels
there's some test clips out there i've
shot some of my own just for kicks
and it's fun but it's not just simply a
higher resolution version
of the already pretty good 4k video
there's like a
laundry list of trade-offs here number
one 8k
is locked at 24 frames per second
max can't go above that and since we all
know 30 fps is the correct frame rate
uh that's just a limitation of the
snapdragon 865 it just can't
quite crank out 30 fps number two it
punches
in a lot so at 4k in normal video mode
it could shoot
pretty wide without binning for 8k but
they use an 8k
window in the middle of the sensor so
when you switch to 8k mode
you see it punch in a ton which really
limits
what you can frame with it number three
focus tracking turns off with 8k
video again this is a limitation of the
processing you get with the snapdragon
e65
but it was already pretty bad without
dual pixel autofocus to begin
with so now it's uh let's be real
really really bad for me it's if you
don't have a clear or far enough away
subject
it's going to be hunting all the time
and that's really distracting and just
doesn't look good on video then number
four because of how much
data is being processed the amount of
time it takes to process from the top
line
to the bottom on that chip it takes a
little bit of time and that creates
rolling shutter and to me it's super
obvious and any footage where you're
moving or turning at all just turns into
jelly
i've never seen rolling shutter this bad
in smartphone video
in my life and then five the file sizes
it's 8k video it's going to be huge it's
about
10 megabytes per second so if you take a
60 second
video you're looking at about 600
megabytes
which is kind of a pain to upload so all
that combines so 8k
video on this phone it's great it's it's
really cool for like
sitting still and maybe capturing some
slow moving or not so much turning
subjects in high resolution
and if you look around that's what most
people are shooting their test clips of
but other than that as soon as you start
to move around or have to chase focus
at all i'll pass i think i'll have
another year or two
of measly 4k video on my smartphone and
be fine i didn't think i'd be the one
saying that but
that's the truth oh and you almost let
me forget to mention the zoom
the thing that's printed on the back of
the phone the 100x space zoom comes from
the 48 megapixel periscope camera
sitting
in the side of this phone okay just
because you have
100x zoom doesn't mean you should
use 100x zoom all the time so my typical
smartphone photo taking behavior is
i almost never zoom i zoom with my feet
or i just switch the ultra wide but the
s20 ultra having this
periscope zoom has made it easier than
ever to just like punch in on subjects
further away
and take crisp photos that's definitely
true this phone takes the sharpest
images
at 30x zoom i've ever seen from a phone
next to huawei
really impressive stuff everybody really
wants to focus on the 100x
like when you zoom all the way in and
it's a cool demo
uh but photos clearly don't look good
at 100x you're not supposed to zoom all
the way into 100 every time honestly
you'd have better luck just taking a 30x
zoom photo
and cropping in later no seriously just
just zoom in later it's
basically the same thing but then
there's of course just people trashing
the 100x zoom because hey you don't need
100x
it looks bad why'd they even put this on
the phone but here's the thing
if you're trashing the 100x zoom because
it looks bad at 100x and you don't think
people need it
but ignoring the 30x that's like
trashing a new speaker that comes out
that goes up to 100 decibels
because it sounds bad at 100 decibels
and no one needs it that loud
but you're forgetting that speaker will
sound better at 50 decibels because it's
in the middle of its range
than the others that are maxing out at
50. so there you go we can appreciate
the good tech when it's there i didn't
mean to turn this whole video into a
camera review but
hey it's one of the most important parts
of the phone so the more you know
the better so as far as numbers go the
108
megapixel number it's there but it's not
quite there but it helps the 100x
number it's not really there all the
time even though it is
i guess printed there all the time and
the 8k number
i actually recommend against using it so
despite all this hype
samsung i think is kind of in the same
place they left off
last year with their camera in third
place
and maybe a software update away from
closing the gap but
third place and then the rest of this
phone is really samsung
doing samsung things if you've used the
galaxy s before you won't be shocked by
anything here
one ui and it's one-handed optimizations
are more important than ever because of
how big this phone is but really it's
still
the super familiar throw in everything
but the kitchen sync strategy there's a
ton
there's a there's a million features on
this phone the one new feature i found
really interesting
was the ability to pin apps to the
massive amount of ram
so in the multitasker if you tap the
icon at the top
you can keep the app open for quick
launching
that loads it up into the ram
permanently and i messed around with
this a bit i tried it with spotify
tried it with the camera app tried it
with my tasks app that i launch all the
time
i didn't really see much of a big
difference in battery so that's nice
and the app really is truly forever open
in the background
ready to launch instantly so having that
much more ram on the phone
is quite useful also i feel obligated to
mention yes this is a 5g phone
but you shouldn't buy this phone just
for the 5g
i'm on 18t i haven't had a single second
of 5g experience on this phone but
you know if you're on t-mobile or any of
the mid-band or millimeter wave using
carriers
your mileage may vary so the strategy of
throwing
all the numbers at the phone did it work
well i think it mostly worked i mean
this is an excellent phone
best in class in several ways the
display being the most incredible one
and with the battery falling right in
step behind it
but as we've learned the numbers aren't
everything and the question a lot of
people seem to like asking
is do you need it and
no of course not most people will do
great with a phone half this price you
don't need this phone but as a fan of
tech i am happy when stuff at the
highest
end is pushing things forward and it's
at the bleeding edge and for a lot of
that stuff
i do like the s20 ultra a lot uh and
some people
who use their phone a lot won't have a
big problem spending a lot extra on it
now shouldn't a 1400
phone be pretty much perfect out the box
yeah probably
and this clearly isn't perfect but
there's a lot of really
great things about it and this is the
phone i will be pocketing personally
until further notice um and i guess
crossing my fingers for some software
updates along the way
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one
peace